hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to chicken saussage a case
of murder
now we played toucan saussage before but
this is a demo for the full game that
they're going to be releasing very soon
in the future and it's a visual novel
with a lot of cutie cutie [ __ ] stuff
welcome to the neighborhood this is an
odd corner of the world with the Sun
never Rises the night something horrible
will take place here we will follow a
ghost named truth and the cat named
sausage who can see them let's begin
shall we
also the cat has strange really long
needle so watch out for that hey it's
okay Tex
don't worry about it so much I know you
well enough by now you didn't mean it
thanks but no it's not okay no hey look
at me really it is if I say it's okay
it's okay
you're right of course I really do need
to start spending more time with you Tex
shuffles anxiously avoiding Bo's gates
ah well actually I've been getting
giving it some thought lately and well I
think we need some time apart you can
take the time to concentrate on your
writing and I can try to get my head
straight I think it will help me see
things clearer Hey whoa it's late right
now we're both pretty worked up how
about we get some rest and think on it
come and see me first thing in the
morning that is that so yeah okay that
sounds like a good idea right don't
worry about it love you Tex makes their
way slowly through the fields listening
to the creatures of the night down the
path towards them a figure approaches
they stop and start as the drunk or
disoriented pausing every so often to
hold their head in their hands and
fidget with the sheet of paper as the
figure gets closer it becomes clear who
it is oh hi okay hi quiz how you doing
hey quiz I'm visiting Bo wanted to talk
the pink rabbit nervously touches the
mask on their face I thought that was
their real face I thought they were
wearing a kicker roomie oh that's a mask
as though to check it's still there of
course you do look quiz it's incredibly
late can it really not wait till morning
it's urgent okay she just headed on home
if you hurry you might still catch her
Thanks night guys yeah
all right textile stand still on the
path watching quiz is it quietly
disappear again into the night when they
can no longer see the pink rabbit he
silently continues on his way okay
gonna get murdered I hate you come and
see what I made I love you're smoking at
what are you doing baking why I've been
watching lots of cooking shows and Wow
have I been getting ideas about what
about what's outage well you are an
overflowing font of good idea the
sausage don't you know it see I'm
thinking if I bake really good I can
have my very own cooking show like on
television this will be it Chuck this is
my ticket back to fame and fortune I can
feel the warm cloves studio lighting on
my fur even now for those of you haven't
seen the first video again links in the
description for that one sausage used to
be an adorable kitten then the rest of
them grew in his face didn't what's the
story behind it okay yep this will
definitely work exactly so anyway I came
up with this pretty 10 out of 10 recipe
and I called you here for its unveiling
okay I'm ready blow me away with your
pure unbridled baking prowess feast your
eyes on this oh my god it's amazing is
that frog dead is that blood
the heck is that my baking yes but what
is it as in what did you place in an
oven in order to pull it's a three layer
lemon torte topped with standing caramel
and chocolate sugar works make lovingly
with me with chilies from Satan's secret
garden ah you do know there's a frog in
there right what frog it's a frog
staring right at me I was using my
Nana's cookbook and everyone
we really ought to burn that book is it
really that bad let me put it like this
if I weren't already dead eating that
would do it damn so maybe cooking just
isn't for me perhaps
well perhaps we can find you a real
cookbook all right I'll go Chuck this
out yet I mean with that the froggy
might be okay
bon voyage Parque begone foul bakery bon
appetit food you know maybe I might give
another recipe a try I saw a really nice
sounding trifle in there really took
advantage of ever underappreciated hoof
trimmings okay what the heck was that
quick let's go see was it murder
oh it was bad okay oh my gosh whoa oh
man what the hell oh hello oh hey what's
going on Lou took recoils violently at
the sight oh man is that whoa I think it
used to be I think I'm gonna be sick are
you just loud in everything you do
bat okay get it all oh that's hardly the
advice to give someone who's vomiting oh
man this really doesn't look like an
accident does it yeah I'm gonna hazard a
guess that no boat can't cut off her own
head with garden shears this was a
murder Chu seems that way okay it's time
for us to shine it's detectives the
neighborhood needs heroes wait what
no there's really the kind of thing you
leave up to the experts it's gonna take
a few hours at least for the cops to get
here from the mainland that's precious
time wasted I'm sure it's what Bo would
have wanted we hardly even know Bo in
that case then we owe it to her you've
lived next door to her for how long
you've never once said hi to her toucan
sausage
detectives Wow Wow whoa whoa whoa okay
took let's get to work
not a moment to lose I hate you okay
whoa
ah how about this no Hey look Bo is
holding on to something it's a photo Oh
No
who is this that's text Bo's boyfriend
there was such a lovely couple we should
really get on the phone with text and
tell him the bad news he needs to know
oh you're still here
I've been about five-way feet away from
you that's all done oh thank you thank
you for that all right well how about
the head or whoa look at this looks like
she was struck on the back of the head I
think she may have died before her head
was removed looks like this pot has been
moved
there's scuff marks all over the ground
it's weird why does this pot get moved
so much let's move it over what a
weird-looking key what this opens no
idea but it looks like a clue do you
think that's everything I just want to
look a little bit longer just got stare
real hard at this site here right
my slander'd is a nice touch I think we
should get some more outdoor lights we
can think about that later especially
with the murderer on the loose I want to
be able to see an attempt on my life and
vivid well-lit detail wouldn't have it
any other way do you think that's
everything it's one look abilities give
me a little give me more time gosh oh
Jesus
what are these flowers those are Luna
roses they grow really well in the
neighborhood because they grow in
moonlight and since it's always night
they thrive here looks as though Bo
really liked them do you think that's
everything just give me some goddamn
second save a guess it's like Bozeman's
potting up plants maybe I could take up
a garden I think that's everything
no okay I think that's everything I
think it's everything yeah okay I'm done
here done searching where to next let's
go check on let's go check on men cuz
men's right here
I don't know what to think about that
let's go ahead take min home and make
sure she's okay
yes she looked pretty shaken okay let's
go all right whatever you see this is
your place yeah it's pretty cozy I wish
I had a house with wheels it does come
in handy I have to admit I was parked
out by the expressway but there was a
huge fire out there last month so I
moved into the neighborhood welcome to
the neighborhood quote unquote TM thanks
sausage boys to the side are you a
magician no I'm psychic Chuck snaps
angrily both unheard and unseen by
minimal she's a fraud and a crook that's
what she is
so I hid stares at Chuck with a shot
nothing sorry I was just imagine how
exciting it must be dad min nods softly
boss smile it's truly a gift okay Oh
welcome to my home oh my gosh it's so
cute in here I love it I'm afraid I'm
gonna have to ask you some questions
about whoa that's okay I expect to be
much do you know anything about this key
at all could say I've ever seen that key
before unfortunately
can you try and contact the coast of bow
at all not easily
whoever killed Bo knew who knew what
they were doing they got their ghost
right into the ground they did he owes
ed was moved in the photo of loved one
was it placed in ban and ensures their
spirit does not remain trapped just go
straight to the other side so it's still
possible to contact her we'll take some
time to prepare but I believe I can I
can't believe you're listening to this
see how come you were at balls I get
there once a week usually bug Rosa heaps
of the roses and I'd like to take some
back here to freshen up please we tend
to chat a while talk about what we're
both doing just a friendly visit
yeah helps break up
I get some flowers and Bogut's our
fortune once a week I take it or
otherworldly gift didn't see this coming
them so strange her fortune was really
positive last week about coming success
huh yeah funny about that fortune
tellers are all crooks and thieves says
the ghost she had good fortune coming
dude that's how I saw it anyway she
pulled the crown of mourning
it's a great card for success and coming
fate does indeed play cruel tricks on us
sometimes you mean you're totally wrong
is that how that me like you as if you
were guessing there's no very much room
well I am a bat and since it's
constantly nighttime here I don't really
need a bed big nuts
naturally nocturnal is another of my
gifts don't you still get tired though
Oh extremely but that's what energy
tributes are for oh babe
the wheels are particularly handy
because I can move in a moment a nice
row if I don't like the neighbors not a
problem I just hit chip and move so how
do you move it though I did have a mule
but it got spooked by that fire near the
expressway a while back in Bolton I got
text and actually to help me pulled it
this time it wasn't far I'm not really
sure I can move it again now right what
there's about 70 cent fortunes I'm
trying to attract business extremely
cheap fortunes to first-time customers
is it working business can you tell by
for dad you don't actually believe in
this [ __ ] do you yes 70 cents as luck or
fate would have it they just so happen
to have exactly 70 cents head bait fair
enough let's see here and quietly allows
you something to draw into three cards
okay pick one of these please allow
yourself a moment and let the cards
speak to you let the choice occur
naturally
I assure you that there's no mere trick
forces at work here beyond our
comprehension my abilities allow me to
delve one hand into the aether and bring
forth glimpses into the coming storm
yeah am I gonna be famous again please
just pick out a card
oh god is a lot of pressure which ones
speaking to me naturally whoa I feel a
great tension in my left butt cheek
this one wonderful head here let me see
well you got the many loving limbs of
spackle does that mean that I have many
fans of which love me and Dearing Lee
and their many hands are gonna rich me
Brittany to shreds
nice smile looks friendly spag bol will
cherish you with his many loving arms
and caress you into a false sense of
security that sounds about right that
sounds like what you guys would do out
there you will then devour you mind and
body that sounds about right
that sounds like what you guys would do
out there oh cool and places the cards
way with expressions this is guidance
right okay yes you're whatever you want
doesn't matter anyway this stuff's all
garbage
okay okay I'm positive the fates will
conspire to bring us back together one
more thing please do be careful the many
loving limbs of spagbol is not a card to
take lightly his dark grasp is closing
in on you well that's a real confidence
booster thanks for the heads up silently
shuffles your card quietly hell's teeth
she's a weird one okay let's see what
Tex has to say all right sure let's go
with that one well is there some kind of
shrine
yeah sure built that quick you can tell
he's been crying then rang me up as soon
as she found Bo such a shock I can't
believe she's good really sorry ruff I
hate him with big guys cry did you see
her it was quick sausage
why do not mention the decapitation she
looked she looked that face cuz her head
was not near her body so she couldn't
see her own death okay good she looked
like she was sleeping like a beautiful
Renaissance painting I had to check I
hadn't fallen through a crack it's
because it diamond landed right in the
Louvre hey let's not push it I keep
expecting her to just walk in you know
like she's just gone down to the shops
or something texts rings his hand
together anxiously can we ask you a few
questions about Bo if it helps catch the
person who did this I'll answer anything
why would Bo be holding a picture of you
what she was holding on to this one
Peter yeah
tix takes a picture and looks it over
rubbing at his eyes well I mean she is
my girlfriend but I'm not sure why she
would be holding on down
weird though she usually keeps his
picture in a frame inside her house
amended saith it might have something to
do with making the her ghost past so far
not that I believe that trash but just
say sausage smiles slyly a chick who
frowns indignantly crossing your wings
and huffing using this key before oh
let's see yeah I have his bows key do
you know it's for pretty sure it's our
save key I know she hides it in the
garden but not sure where the safe is in
her house ah so it's a safe key
thanks Dex what did you last see Bo was
dropping her off at home after leaving
Exley's place excellent yeah we tend to
go around Exley's once a week for a game
night we play a board game called
journey to gobbler
oh there are none deed Undead cheap I
think it's hard to tell with those
undead cattle they all start to look the
same after I said good night to Bo and
dropped her at home I met a friend of
hers called quiz said they were going to
drop in on Bo the last person to see
Bohr live who's a such a weirdo I knew I
should have stopped them all weird
interesting Thanks we should probably go
check on this undead quiz - all right
I've done a square sex see you later
please do I'll do anything to help find
Bo's killer but I'm not done suspecting
you sure was nice of us to text give us
a key to Bo's ass but you're trusting if
you ask me okay let's see if there's any
clues let's get to work investigation
mode you guys help me point out what you
think is investigation worthy you guys
see anything see nothing but these
whites good call
Chris alright Bo had such nice taste
certainly has a theme alright
really nice orchard good good pointing
that out
April alright I'll be taking that on the
way out I think it'll look pretty nice
on top of the TV all right what next are
the computer dragon you got the best
ideas
Hey look bought a computer no way not
after last time
okay let's see here yeah it looks like
she had a password damn you think we can
hack it
you okay first type really fast yeah I'm
watching
alright huh yeah and they're below
computer words it's like a spell I think
all right you go first
open-source programming your median
JavaScript HDL my firewall we just queue
individual base it will be able to
create a GUI in c++ c sure oh please no
no computed birds help me Mac and rest
kernels web developer I think
something's happening it's working oh
[Music]
wow the computers broken well
guru meditation error welp that didn't
work at all Greg god dammit that was a
bad suggestion all right how about this
dragon ah so man the wrong way tidy out
there I'll but really like their books
his books have some really weird titles
how to shave your pet hamster in a
hundred and five fashionable ways okay
ah Steve the carpet good call seating
its own tail so you're planning
something horrible more books all those
do look comfy confirm they are comfy
stop bouncing around on them alright
it's clear and peaceful night into the
neighborhood sausage someone just got
murdered what's clear and it's also
night so I got most of this pong right
it's always night pictures of dragons
how does someone a shadow twin from
another dimension and trap them inside a
television oh that one from the first
game go check out the first video if you
haven't seen that Wow okay well that's
not what I meant all right we're back
okay there hey this is a cool picture
have a look wow that's awesome we should
have a picture like this back at our
place we could put it where the big cow
head is instead yeah the fact Bo won't
even miss it so I say we take it home
and try it out whoa where we are it's
this
sweeter still gotta keep open sesame'
sad no it looks like a load of paper and
stuff looks like the load of notes
written by Bo about quiz it's such a
weird name your name is spelled SOS IG
sausage mouths it's drugs nonchalantly
my mom had trouble spelling whatever
there we go the dragon is happy good
Ryan do you think we're done here
ah probably I can't wait oh there's some
on the Shelf there what's that really
nice orchard all right we're down here
okay done searching you tell more people
I want to go chat too let's see you this
quiz person is because that's the person
that I'm most suspecting at this
juncture my quiz I'm asked sure looks
like one why are you wearing a mask it
helps I'm sure you like to hide buying
that I can see what text isn't fond of
this one it helps me Cody can I ask you
something about Bo sure yeah let's go of
the thing we found this a bose place it
in a safe what is all this
he found it what is this my diary my
experiences I was helping so what's
written in here this is all true yes it
helps me see everything you were the
last to see Bo alive can you tell me
what happened I was skynyrd scared about
what I went to see Bo about letter huh
letter there was a letter quiz looked
straight ad for a few moments finds a
crumpled letter and hands it to you
shakily don't publish the word the
manuscript was gonna be published here
O's idea said it would help me grow
after this had second thoughts
what are those statues to make them when
I close my eyes if there they are you
see things if I carve them not so much
okay
oh do you see that see what it's nothing
ghost okay returned the diary to quiz I
think you should have this back
sausage hands the manuscript over is it
really a good idea I don't know seems
like the right thing to do I didn't have
any other option so there we are
if you say so thanks Chris holds the
paint just tightly to their chest dad
thick daughter like a dead bird I'll go
problem thank you
we're still clings to the pile of papers
while waving at you alright I don't know
if you're a murderer but thumbs off oh
wow actually really is undead you don't
see many of these days they tend to
carry the whole fire and pitchfork
falling with you I do cattle become
undead in the neighborhood something to
do with the stone circle I think a curse
absorbs pretty cold and they can run a
pub our lovely fluffy zombie
entrepreneur awhile sausage you really
shouldn't use the Z word it's really
super offensive
hello and welcome so your undead that
last movie yes it does make running this
establishment difficult not many wanna
undead serve drinks I pull the facts
pebble here works at the bar and I can
concentrate on
gonna give you a drink oh no actually I
just want ask some questions about bow
it really was distressing news to hear
port bow we only saw her last night how
was last night it wasn't completely out
of the ordinary here's a fairly regular
game night although we were on the cusp
of defeating the Goblin which went x-bow
at an unfortunate disagreement yeah I
was really kind of annoying like we had
to cut the game session short because of
it it's somewhat inconvenient it happens
all the time yeah who Texas a wild
temper that's for sure like BAM there's
no in-between with him
so tacks off an argument bow
unfortunately yes is somewhat prone to
unpredictable mood swings you can't be
putting it lightly we speculate that is
due to his well how can I put this
politely is breed
huh what do you mean he's pimple dude Oh
pit bulls are adorable now we don't know
that for sure that's just a rumor you
just have to look at him well you can
for sure see it when he gets angry he's
all like girl this anthem song game not
can be pretty wild
anyway Saxon boat would usually settle
the differences in short time yeah how
well did you know bow oh it's a pretty
sweet girl kind chill like the books she
was a rider of sorts working from home
on novels yes she spent a ton of time on
a computer just write me have you ever
read any of her books no visually
shuffles nervously I'll bet she wrote
some serious mud okay
have all smiles impishly laughing into
his paws oh I see
ask them where we can buy it for
research no do you know what the
argument was about well hell if I know
they'd argue a lot well I dunno it might
have been on the subject of quiz
actually that it was regarding all the
time quiz was better be bold oh yeah
quitter
Tex was getting jealous right tweezing
bow we're riding some book together Tex
was all like you spent more time with
that mask weirdo there me then Bose out
crying in there laughs yeesh I think I'm
done here thanks for talking with us
before you go you should really try
something from the new cocktail menu
detective work is nasty work ever looks
at you with full of hope I'm so very
sorry he's really been trying to push
this cocktail menu that he just create
come on look at his little face he'll be
crushed sure yes oh ah
the bad oh the bad bird those bird boobs
from that bird is that those bird boobs
the Z word before I like the shadow
creature I'm gonna go for the shadow
creature who is shadow creature I like
this one it takes a black curtain spices
and it looks right back II what do you
reckon sounds are going to be I don't
need second thoughts that's good for me
except excellent I'll read with this one
up right away
he's been dying to make a cocktail you
got this
my little bartender set for a few new
year and he won't stop trying to do this
bartender stunts
it's called Flair bartending and boy do
I have Flair
drink up you'll have a spring in your
step now
thank you for Hubert thanks for the
drink
hey good luck Wiggles all right cool
what are you thinking - anything I'm
thinking maybe we see our men's getting
on with the plan to contact boat really
okay let's go see what the mad bats
cooked up all right what's going on over
there not really sure oh yeah it's what
I was telling you about earlier it's a
phone to the other side Oh yep this will
definitely work it's a phone on top of a
scab a board I simple is best okay so
how does work it does not work okay so
you write your question in scatter
letters it has to be pretty short due to
the limited time you leave the phone off
the hook and Dow the dead person's
double grab sausages and holds it
tightly and excited then you hold hands
the coast rings the phone no they don't
okay I think it's all set up did you
take long to set up board itself no the
ambiance however needs to be finely
tuned the candles are everything we
learned some stuff we found a diary pose
place it was all about quiz so we gave
it to them you just handed it right back
huh
oh stop bow worked alone on writing
now for this one anyway hey ma'am
Wiggles I got run back to the pub cuz
it's gonna be opening time soon and
actually a wonder where I win I just had
to come by and see the ghost phone
though so cool thank you for helping
Apple get my loved eggs Lee laters all
right can we contact her yep I think I
can if you have a Bo's number I'll dial
it in ah I don't know Bo's telephone
number oh that could be a problem what
you don't know it she lived next door
does this work well it should
I'm pretty sure I set it up just like I
haven't tested it I'm pretty confident
in oh boy okay all right we'll be back
we gotta go find Bo's number carry back
and be right here alright see ya
tax would know he's bound to know it
just a little bit below well then we get
to use the ghost phone
don't get your hopes up
ah [ __ ] it is Oh why would anyone want
to kill quiz ah text might they were a
little creepy but they seemed harmless
what a shame this war is really the only
outcome in the demo oh no poor quiz is
gonna endure this a few more times
hang in there quiz you're a trooper
taking it for the team Oh No ah ah I
love it I love it I love it so much I
love it so much I can't wait to play the
full game of this one it is so cool it's
so adorable and also really brutal and
that's a nice combination sometimes so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you think down the
comments below and remember you can
check out the first video it's down
there description as well also there are
still tickets on sale for the tour check
it out we're gonna be going on tour in
two weeks so go - markiplier calm or
check out the link in the description
below go same place check out where
we're playing if we're a city near you
we've got a full show that we're doing
it's super fun a lot of comedy stuff and
should be a great time so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you
[Music]